he also mentioned that this insistence
that there is no
skill or competence or that we're all
equal in some manner is one of the
reasons why we're at a societal
stagnation point okay so firstly what's
meant by this stagnation and then how is
it
drawn from this insistence on equality
of skill or merit and so on
well okay so to go back to that
insistence
it comes from something that's true
originally and it's just over
extrapolated right the thing that's true
is that
you know we're all born here and none of
us is better than anybody else and
we're all equivalent to each other in
some way right there but for the grace
of god go i kind of realization right um
but that doesn't mean you can't make bad
choices and that doesn't mean that
in fact
i mean okay see when you talk start
talking about spiritual stuff
um
let me just
when you start talking about spiritual
stuff
you almost can't say anything
because what even what i just said is
not actually true that you can't
of course you can't make bad choices
um it's actually not possible to make
bad choices but
if you go to the world
of human beings just trying to do human
being life stuff then you can make bad
choices right so
um
we we somehow have a society where
we kind of want to think that that's not
true like if somebody
if somebody ends up in an unfortunate
place it's because of the forces that
were acting on them right they were
under privileged and had a bad
you know
were under you fell into the undertow of
society whatever right
and all that is true
to some degree
but at the same time
if
if we don't have
this idea that people are
also responsible for themselves
there's no energy to go to a good place
that comes from anywhere right
so if you want to go to a good place
there are some
attitudes
that are much more conducive to that
than other attitudes and i think
we've got some attitudes that
don't help and
you know personally
i see this at all levels of society so
like if you look at people who are the
experts in various things
or who
uh who are the societally um
designated experts like the people who
have the degrees
the people who have the positions in
government and whatever i don't think
most of those people are very good at
what they do there are occasional
outliers right but for the most part
it's just we set up a system of how do
you rise in the ranks of these various
things
um
those systems were founded
originally
in ways that were functional
you know like
like originally having a phd was a
really big deal right
now it's
well and when we set up that system
it was a system to help with that kind
of learning and discovery of new
knowledge now getting a phd is basically
filling out a tax form
but
it takes four or five years um not for
everybody some people do phds that are
actually
closer to the spirit of what the
original thing was but
we've kind of slowly over time replaced
the original thing with this other thing
that is actually quite different right
and
produces different output and
um
you know
there are consequences to that i think
and
that's all i mean we're getting into
like personal rants at this point
um
but that's that's how i feel about it
when you were talking about the problems
with our culture you also mentioned
stagnation and around since 1970 or so
um or mid-1970s peter thiel and eric
weinstein have thoughts on that i'm
curious if you've seen their thoughts or
heard their thoughts yeah i've seen a
bunch that both of those guys have said
um i have a relatively contrarian view
here
in that i agree with peter thiel but
about the general state of things but i
also think that he's a little too
charitable because what he says is
that the domain of software is
most of the
advancement in recent decades
i actually don't think that's true i
think software stopped advancing around
1990 for the most part we've had small
things that happened but
i think
this is an area where people are pretty
confused about if they don't
think about it all the time because they
look and they say what do you mean
there's all these web companies there's
all these websites they're ipoing
there's like billions of dollars and all
that but what's really happening there
is technologies that we figured out in
prior decades like integrated circuits
that go very fast made by companies like
intel
amd whatever you know various chip fabs
and all this stuff
combined with like networking and
communications hardware and the material
science that went into that
have made this scenario where you can
have software
that a lot of people use and that's
network connected in a very easy way
right that's actually what created all
of this the actual software in most
cases is pretty dumb and pretty bad and
doesn't really have
new ideas because it doesn't have to
because
you know if you want to make a website
that makes a bunch of money it's not
like you have to have some new
technical software idea to make that
work you just need to make the website
and we've actually known the technology
that you need to work make the website
we've known since like 1965.
none of that stuff is new um well let's
if we're talking about networking
specifically let's say 1975 to like give
it more time to percolate but like by
1975 you basically had everything that
you need to build a modern website it's
just we've made it a lot more
complicated than it needs to be
and so people think
people think that things are more rocket
sciencey than they actually are
and so
um when peter thiel says like one of his
big
catch phrases i i don't want to you know
that's a little bit of a denigrating way
to say it but like
he says you know we've had very little
progress in the world of atoms and
mostly in the world of bits i don't
think we've had very much progress in
the world of bits what we've had is the
use of the world of bits to generate a
lot of economic
windfall which is legitimate right
because we're replacing all sorts of
things that used to have large costs due
to requiring physical manufacturing and
all this stuff right and so those costs
go away so i think it makes sense that
companies make money by replacing that
but that's not
technological advancement
at all it's just
figuring out how to apply computers to
food delivery or whatever right
so
the other way that i say this is uh
like like everybody in silicon valley
says they work in tech right like oh i
work in tech um i don't think almost any
of these companies are tech companies so
for example uh
if you meet a truck driver and he's
driving at just a regular truck not even
a tesla electric truck or anything a
regular old diesel truck and he's
driving
across the interstate from you know
texas to california to deliver a bunch
of goods does he work in tech
and the answer is probably not
right
um but a truck actually
was amazing technology at some time that
was completely new and even a modern
truck is an iterated refined much better
truck than what we originally knew how
to make so he is driving this amazing
technological artifact right but like we
don't say he works in tech he works in
the application of a particular piece of
technology to
transport and that's not to say anything
you know negative about truck drivers
like those dudes if they all quit right
now we would be in a lot of trouble like
we should have a great deal of respect
for what they do um
but like there's this pretend that goes
on that what's happening at all these
web companies is fundamentally different
from that but it's not
there it's basically driving trucks
from the database to the web client
right
but they make it a lot harder than it
has to be so it seems like it's more
than that